aurélie schnyder n'a pas bougé à elle
est géniale pour une danseuse c'est dur
mignonne comme tout est le boucher henry
mais il vient un moment où il va pouvoir
se barrent les intéresse bien alors
intervenue lé jeu vertus sur des
questions très con donc vous pouvez
répondre très connus comme comme avons
quoi qu'ils jugent comme avant vous
préférez votre père ou votre mère ma
mère par la force des choses vous
préférez hitler ou staline dans la
famille on n'a pas vraiment apprécié
hitler staline règles connues par
ouï-dire alors vous partez trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial c'est un
classique as vous préféré partir alors
avec sarkozy que vous avez appelé lapin
duracell s'est bien trouvés je vous
félicite c'est bien trouvé la fin du
ressel quand vous partez avec sarkozy
douste-blazy ou françois hollande dans
un vaisseau spatial oui pendant trois
ans non moi je porte pas bien tu es
obligé de partir obligé de parler
douste-blazy sarkozy ou françois
hollande oui
j'emmène roland nous sommes allées à
hollande
je connais pas ouais je peux pas
comprendre qu'on paie est ce que vous
trouvez plus de circonstances
atténuantes un vieux qui se tape des
petites
un but qui esthétique ou un jeune qui
tape son des vielles à roue premier 1
bah oui il ya les salons un au revoir
but si vous préférez un président
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou pas d'élection du tout ces
salons comme le sevrage universel ah
ouais ouais si vous ça ne peut pas
arriver si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop vous seriez quoi comme objet
tout en sachant que nous l'aurait dans
le cur
vous seriez quoi je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'on vende sex-shop
on va emplois dans les 5 ch a il faut
répondre williams vous êtes en vendant
un sex-shop vous êtes quoi pas de langue
de bois il n'a pas la langue de bois
dans les sections avait fait sensation
mais très sincèrement à part des
godemichés des films c'est parce qu'on
vend dans les sex-shops règles michel
donc je me vois pas été utilisé voilà un
film à moi tout seul donc savourer
forcément l'autre
l'autre fait vous préférez une femme
alors ça c'est très important
vous préférez une famille une épouse une
maîtresse qui baisent mal etc et fidèle
winky baisse bien mais qu l'infidèle
c'est terrible c'est terrible mais c'est
que des questions oui mais en ce moment
je dois faire la première à huy ouais
mais si vous préférez une femme qui
baise main le mec est fidèle ouais c'est
bizarre c'est pas du tout comme tu
préfères quoi toi il peut aller ailleurs
ouais c'est pas c'est pas moi qu'on pose
la question moi j'ai droit de faire ce
que je veux henry vous préférez quoi
vous pourquoi moi qui bosse mâles et qui
est finalement celle qui bossent bien
mais je suis casé à aa
je sais pas vous poser la question elle
préfère un mec qui bosse bien mais qu'un
infidèle
le coup quand le malheur aurélie dupont
c'est normal
alors attention william abitbol vous
reconcentrer s'il vous plaît vous
passeriez plus volontiers la nuit avec
anne sinclair à regarder des cassettes à
ce point - avenue du monde oui en ce
moment là du temps avec anne sinclair
lors sinclair ou bob sinclair lors c'est
clair lorsque claire c'est pour corriger
la première fois laissé échapper que les
anciens pairs bages et canal+ ouais vous
seriez plus surprise si on vous trouvez
au lit avec un mec avec deux filles un
mec
ah oui ça bouge ça serait plus choquant
pour vous bon sang je serai ce mois
surprise ouais d'accord